football night in America is an NBC
sports Peter King here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you sir what's going on
Peter everything's going good rich how
about you all right I know you hit it
you're football morning in America peace
that was available on Labor Day great
Labor Day reading for everybody I'll
start why did Khalil Mack have to get
traded Peter it's question of the year
in the NFL in my opinion I think it's
one of the crazier things I've seen in
recent years covering the NFL I think
you draft players to develop them into
Khalil knack on and off the field this
is a it's a guy who is a great example a
great leader and a great football player
pro Football Focus metrics say that in
the last two years
his 175 quarterback disruption sacks
hits pressures of the quarterback is far
and away better than any pass rusher in
football
so he's 27 years old he's due to get
paid and I'm shocked that the Raiders
basically threw their hands in the air
and said nothing we can do about it
we can't pay him we're not going to pay
to guys big money on our team so they
got rid of them and as I explained in my
column if the salary cap continues on
the path that it has been on over the
last five years no guarantee but if it
does continue on that path then over the
next six years over the next seven years
rather Khalil nak will take up ten point
seven percent of his team's salary cap
with this new contract now if you
develop a big big star on your team and
you decide that he's not worth one tenth
of your cap I think you need to get into
another line of business well and then
what factor in what a franchise paid
quarterback would make I mean so that
would be two players maybe if they take
up 25% of your cap you should still be
able to quite be 25 so what would it be
probably about 23 but I agree with you
I think you can look at a lot of Super
Bowl champions since the beginning of
the salary cap era and you can look at
the Super Bowl championship teams and
find many who the top two players on
their team is cooking up one corner of
their cap and in my opinion to use that
as an accessible Mac especially with the
Raiders grim history of high draft
choices I don't understand what they're
doing so then what the hell happened
Peter I mean Gruden knows football I
mean and look it's no surprising Rudin
would come in and remake the roster on
his own in his own way I mean that's
what he's done everywhere and it's no
surprise that he's rid himself of every
other quarterback not named Caron and
traded for AJ McCarron I mean that's it
that says Gruden e a move as there as
there is so that's not a surprise but
what why couldn't this happened I don't
understand was this was this a power
play for Gruden to say he's the man I
mean that makes that makes no I don't
sense I mean what is it our play I think
it was groot ins but Gruden clearly is
behind this and Gruden believes that I'm
not gonna pay I'm not gonna pay a guy
who and they'll probably come up with
all alternate numbers to my 10 10.7% but
I'm not gonna pay a guy 1/6 the 1/7 of
our salary cap it's just way too much
I'm gonna pay a quarterback and I'm not
really going to pay anybody else I'm
gonna we're gonna pay him but we're not
going to pay him to the level that that
Mac wants I think two things are curious
about this rich I have heard we've all
heard the rumors there the Raiders are
cash poor and which I really do not buy
and when I was at camp I asked a couple
of people there I thought would know and
they said no we can we can make this
deal we can do this I think I think but
I think I think it's I think Mark Davis
or Reggie McKenzie somebody has to come
out and say that this was not a we could
have made this deal we had the cash to
make this deal
if we wanted to we just didn't want to I
think that's number one I think number
two in my opinion I just think it is
disingenuous to say that you can't pay
two players this much money and then
expect to be able to feel the
competitive team then then then listen
then trade all of your ones okay and get
a bunch of twos and threes so you can
you can keep players on the path of of
paying them but not paying them like
superstars I just I think it's I don't
think the Raiders have been fully
transparent in this deal well the last
one for you on this Peter King is that
that this is why they're paying Gruden
the big bucks that that that he is
making ten million more guaranteed
dollars over the life of his contract
they were willing to give Khalil Mack in
the short a period of time and that now
he's got to sell this to a veteran Laden
locker room and and still get more free
agents to come here and tell kids who
drafts that we will pay you if you do
everything right he still has to beat us
there's no player right now in my
opinion who's under more pressure there
are some players over/under as much but
there's no player is under more pressure
right now going into this season and
Derek Carr because the Raiders already
had a subpar defense and now far and
away the best player on defense is gone
that means that Derek Carr is gonna have
to make is gonna have to he's gonna have
to put up you know 30 points a game on
average this season for the Raiders to
have a chance in my opinion to make the
playoffs I I mean what do you what are
you saying to your team I and look Derek
Carr came back with a hey we got a was
that a get together we've got a big
season coming up and blah blah blah
whatever he said on Twitter his first
tweet it was a lot more a lot more
indicative of what he truly feels which
is no way that's right as well we can't
no blanking way and though I look at it
and and I just say you're absolutely
right this is not going to be a good
year for the Raiders number one and
number two in the offseason when you try
to make free agents come I don't know
how you're gonna do that
Peter King here on the Rich Eisen show
what is going on in the camp of levy on
bail Peter because he can't get a
long-term deal from the Steelers right
now by rule the Steelers and he can't
talk long-term deal because of the
franchise tag he can make a little bit
more money on the tender I guess if the
Steelers want to sweeten the pot and he
did just see Khalil Mack get a trade
away so what why is he showing up if he
wants to say he wants to win football
games and have a big season he he's got
a he's got to show up right now to play
this weekend a big question I think the
about about Le'Veon Bell right now
without any question the biggest thing I
want to know is just what is his goal
here and it seems to me that his goal is
I want to make it so more unpleasant for
the Steelers that they are going to find
a place to trade me that's how I look at
it rich I'm not positive that this is
the case but I think that Le'Veon Bell
now at this point really wants to go
somewhere else what else is the logical
interpretation of why he's doing this
well Pouncy says he's going to show up
on on on Wednesday I mean which I guess
if he shows out Wednesday that would
Tomlin dare just say you're sitting I
mean would date would he question this
mean Tomlin this putting Tomlin in a
terrible fix because part of me thinks
and we've seen it over time when the win
holdouts
I was just saw with a real quantum is
what happened to real kwan smith about
three practices into is his bear tenure
after sitting out almost a month got a
hamstring tweak and the same thing
happens a lot of times the players who
held out regardless of what they've been
doing to keep in shape and so I don't
know if you're Tomlin
even if he shows up I think you have to
say look we're going to Cleveland we're
going to have lay beyond inactive and
we're going to try to win this first
game without them you know shouldn't the
Pittsburgh Steelers be able to beat the
Cleveland Browns
even the rejuvenated Cleveland Browns on
the road without Le'Veon Bell look if
they can't uh it's a it's a grim scene
in Pittsburgh does Earl Thomas show up
in Seattle soon what do you think I
think John Schneider has made it very
very clear that you better come with a
good offer and I have heard that he's
not taking anything less than two for
Thomas and maybe not even a two so we'll
see but but again you know I think that
people now are skeptical of taking a guy
at not a huge Meade position as is
viewed by the NFL paying a to when a guy
clearly is in the last I don't know what
three years of his career I don't know
but I think that Earl Thomas basically
is not gonna have a choice if he wants
to play football I think he's gonna have
to go to Seattle a couple more minutes
left with Peter King here on the Rich
Eisen show what are you hearing about
from NFL headquarters about their main
apparel partner putting somebody who's
suing them and the face front of their
new just do it campaign how is that
sitting between Nike I mean I'm sorry I
have not asked anybody that question
today Chris I I mean there's no question
that it's that it has to be
discomforting for them no question about
it
and the NFL clearly you know I've said
this I don't know last year or so that
you know this is a league that somehow
someway got Michael Sam drafted okay
even though as it turns out he wasn't
you know he wasn't the player that that
maybe people thought he was at Missouri
he didn't turn out to be a very good
football player but they found a way to
get him drafted and in my opinion that
has the NFL's fingerprints on
getting the Rams to draft Michael Sam
everybody denied it I'm sorry I'm a
little skeptical of those denials but in
and you're telling me right now that
that this guy who five years ago five
plus years ago led a team to the Super
Bowl and had one of the most
electrifying playoff games in green
against Green Bay that that any
quarterback has ever had in the history
of the league it's just it's silly to
think that that he doesn't have a spot
in the NFL and I just think it's it
people are so spooked right now over you
know the the anthem protest and the
anthem issue that's not why he's in the
league but I applaud Nike I think it's
fantastic to me and again I'm not
predicting this will happen but I'm just
telling you what this reminds me of the
rancor and the controversy surrounding
Colin Kaepernick right now reminds me
when I was a kid of the rancor and
controversy that survived that that
surrounded Cassius Clay who became
Muhammad Ali it just does
and I think down the road Colin
Kaepernick is going to be viewed as a
historic figure as much as people blanch
at that who don't like him or don't like
his politics everybody thought the exact
same stuff about Muhammad Ali and look
when he died it was like a president
died it was like having a state funeral
for him so I just I think that the NFL
in you know in retrospect down the line
is going to look very very small and not
allowing Colin Kaepernick to play last
one for you Peter for those who did not
read your football morning in America
column your Super Bowl prediction is I
picked the Rams over the Patriots I wish
I liked somebody better than the
Patriots because that right now in the
AFC because the Patriots are flawed and
I just I mean it it I'm just I I don't
like the the Houston offensive line I
don't like I'm just not sure about the
Jacksonville offense
as good a day as they had against the
Steelers in the playoffs I think the
Steelers defense was eminently flawed in
that you know at the end of the season
after they lost she's ear but but I I
just think right now everywhere I look
with the Rams they've had a very very
good off season I do agree with people
this might might not last but right now
I think the the Rams are the team with
the least amount of major questions of
any team in football Peter love the
chats as always let's let's do it on the
regular now that the season is upon us
thanks so much have a great day
right back at you at Peter underscore
King the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience